[Música]
en las últimas semanas el brote de Kobe
19 en China ha generado preocupación en
la comunidad internacional el panorama
en ese país asiático es bastante
complejo los servicios sanitarios y
también los servicios funerarios están
saturados el aumento de los casos afecta
principalmente a las grandes ciudades
del este del país y la reapertura de las
fronteras chinas también le preocupa a
otros países de la comunidad
internacional por la llegada de viajeros
procedentes de China o ciudadanos chinos
que vayan hacia otras partes del mundo
como por ejemplo Europa y Estados Unidos
Pero lo que más preocupa Es la falta de
estadísticas los números oficiales sobre
la situación el gobierno chino ha dado
datos ha dado información pero a
cuentagotas y esto le preocupa
principalmente a la OMS escuchemos
la OMS todavía cree que las muertes en
China no se notifican en gran medida y
esto está relacionado con las
definiciones que se utilizan
pero también con la necesidad de que los
médicos y los que informan en el sistema
de salud pública se animen a informar
estos casos y no sean desalentados
pues las imágenes de los hospitales
saturados en diferentes ciudades de
China nos recuerdan a los hechos del año
2020 unas imágenes que son difíciles de
olvidar para la comunidad internacional
por eso también una docena de países han
impuesto restricciones justamente a Los
viajeros procedentes de China La
pregunta es si esto de verdad tiene un
impacto verdadero para prevenir futuros
contagios Beijing ha calificado esas
restricciones como una medida política y
no sanitaria escuchemos
Lamentablemente un pequeño número de
países aún insisten adoptar
restricciones de entrada
discriminatorias contra china sin tener
en cuenta los hechos científicos y la
situación real de la epidemia en sus
propios países china se opone firmemente
a esto y tomará medidas recíprocas
una vez más hacemos un llamado a los
países a formular medidas de prevención
de epidemia científicas y apropiadas y
no aprovechar la oportunidad para
participar en la manipulación política
Pero así como algunos países imponen
restricciones otros si le ven el
completo potencial económico que tienen
los turistas chinos y su importancia su
importancia para la reactivación
económica países como Tailandia como
Vietnam como Indonesia han abierto Las
puertas de par en par para los turistas
chinos sin importar el rebrote de Kobe
19 que está viviendo la nación asiática
veamos el reportaje que preparó la
redacción de France 24
Tailandia recupera su potencial Y es que
esta nación de Asia un destino preferido
para disfrutar del asueto de año nuevo
empezó a recibir a ciudadanos chinos que
viajaron tras el levantamiento de la
política cero covid estamos emocionadas
de volver a Tailandia hemos estado
esperando durante tres años la política
cero covid surgió tras el brote de Kobe
19 en China con la intención de
erradicar por completo la enfermedad
pero ante el impacto que generó en la
economía y la vida cotidiana las
autoridades decidieron levantarla no
obstante el temor existente por los
contagios surgidos en China durante las
últimas semanas llevó a la OMS a
pronunciarse a fin de evitar lo que
definió como medidas discriminatorias
compartimos la opinión actual del centro
europeo para el control de enfermedades
que un aumento en curso en China no se
prevé que tenga un impacto significativo
en la situación epidemiológica del covi
19 en la región europea en este momento
Corea del Sur y Japón anunciaron la
imposición de medidas restrictivas
contra Los viajeros chinos y como
respuesta Beijing suspendió la emisión
de visas para ciudadanos de estos países
una situación que se presenta en medio
del optimismo de los vendedores
surcoreanos por la llegada de los
turistas chinos
Por qué china está siendo testigo de
este rebrote de Kobe 19 que deja
entonces esa política de tres años de
serocovit instaurada en ese país y qué
riesgo representa esto para el resto del
mundo estas y otras preguntas pues se
las vamos a consultar a nuestros
invitados del día de hoy en el debate de
France 24 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a ella es médica page Dn
epidemiologías también profesora de la
Facultad de Medicina de la pontificia
universidad javeriana también está con
nosotros Daniel López Acuña epidemiólogo
y exdirector de acción sanitaria de la
OMS y aquí en el estudio de France 24
nos acompaña la doctora María Fernanda
Gutiérrez ella es médica y viróloga a
los tres les agradezco por estar con
nosotros aquí en el debate de France 24
a nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también son parte de este debate pueden
dejar sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@antilogo
y les recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn Pues muy
bien teniendo ya el panorama un poco más
claro de lo que está sucediendo aquí en
con esta situación en China vamos a dar
entonces inicio al debate saludo
entonces a la doctora azul macuco Nova
para conocer las primeras impresiones
Punto de partida de El Debate Doctora
gracias por estar con nosotros y El
Punto de partida es que deja Entonces
estos tres años de política de cero
covid que instauró el gobierno chino y
que ahora están enfrentando este rebrote
de contagios de Kobe 19 Cuál es su
balance
cordial saludo Muchas gracias por la
invitación a este programa bueno China
es uno de los pocos países en el mundo
que si yo esta política de cero covid
recordemos Que varios países del sudeste
asiático siguieron esta política Pero
principalmente en 2020 cuando no
existían vacunas una vez lograron altas
tasas de vacunación en su población
pasaron de esta política de cero covid a
una política mucho más permisiva sin sin
tantas restricciones sin embargo china
insistió en este enfoque hasta el pasado
diciembre es decir el 7 de diciembre de
2022 es cuando china cambia
completamente su enfoque de cero covid a
una política de mitigación mitigación es
decir a tratar de reducir el impacto
sobre la severidad de la enfermedad pero
no tanto el impacto sobre la infección
sí doctora paso a darle la la palabra
ahora a Daniel para terminar la ronda
aquí en el estudio de France 24 Daniel
su opinión sobre sobre esta política de
cero covid que tuvo china a lo largo de
estos años qué balance puede hacer usted
dio resultado en su momento y tal vez
para el contexto en el que estamos ahora
la forma de hacer frente a estos
rebrotes debe ser distinta como lo está
haciendo China o cuál es el análisis que
usted hace
Bueno lo primero es señalar que la
política de cero covid que fue aplicada
en muchos países Tuvo una razón de ser y
en China particularmente fue una
política adecuada mientras no había el
desarrollo de un instrumento como la la
vacunación porque es lo único que
permitió evitar millones de contagios y
millones de fallecimientos por covid en
la etapa inicial de la pandemia
yo creo que para entender lo que está
pasando en China que es un es un asunto
complejo hay que entender que no es
únicamente dar marcha atrás con respecto
a la política de covid cero sino que es
que se está enfrentando una presión
social por las restricciones a veces con
métodos dictatoriales que ha existido
pero en una en un escenario
epidemiológico en donde no ha habido una
suficiente vacunación de la población Y
en donde la vacuna que ha sido utilizada
las vacunas chinas por este nacionalismo
vacunal que ha existido en el mundo en
torno a la pandemia no es Igualmente
eficaz que la vacuna de rna y mucho
menos que la vacuna bivalente de la que
ahora se dispone en algunos países y que
lamentablemente no se ponen otros
entonces en pocas palabras china levantó
las restricciones inoportunamente porque
no había preparado adecuadamente las
condiciones con una suficiente cobertura
vacunal y con vacunas que tuvieran
suficiente eficacia y por eso vemos los
millones de contagios las
hospitalizaciones el colapso asistencial
y los fallecimientos Yo creo que es
importante no entrar en el debate de
todo o nada blanco o negro con respecto
a la a la política de covid cero hay que
contextualizarlo muy bien
claro y así tal vez es como lo presentó
el gobierno chino era su gran apuesta
para evitar el avance de la pandemia en
su momento Pero ahora creo que la
respuesta Pues usted lo estaba diciendo
Daniel debe ser una conjunción de
vacunas de buen despliegue de vacunación
y también de políticas acertadas Ya lo
vamos a seguir analizando para terminar
esta ronda a la doctora María Fernanda
aquí en el estudio de France 24 también
le doy la bienvenida Gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros y su punto de vista
qué deja este balance que se puede hacer
de la política cero covid de China bueno
Yo estoy de acuerdo con con ellos con
respecto a lo que contestan a mí hay una
cosa que me sigue preocupando es la la
verdad en China a mí me parece que china
ha dejado de decir la verdad y la dejó
de decir desde el principio eso es una
de las cosas que uno no termina Pues de
tomar una posición Clara con respecto a
eso la otra discusión es que es un país
con muchísima gente entonces obviamente
los números son muy exagerados para todo
entonces se están muriendo millones de
personas Pero proporcionalmente el
número pues si lo comparamos con el
número de población pues se ha salido
más o menos no no mucho de los
parámetros esperados o lo que vimos en
el resto de los países y sí pues hay
mucha gente se ha reportado mucha gente
mayor con comorbilidades Con
inmunodeficiencias que no se vacunó
cuando era la grupo de gente que más lo
estaba necesitando y quizás es el grupo
de personas que ahora está viéndose más
golpeada pero de todas maneras a toda
esta historia A mí sí me gustaría que
pasen un par de años para que sepamos la
verdad de lo que pasó en China de lo que
ha pasado y de cómo se ha manejado la
situación ha habido muchos secretismo a
lo largo de estos años en torno a las
cifras en torno al desarrollo del virus
es apropiado decir en este momento
doctora María Fernanda si ustedes ya
pueden tener como una especie de su
propia teoría de que pudo haber pasado
en China que de origen al al coronavirus
y al Coby 19 y al inicio de esta
pandemia Cuál es su teoría mire lo que
yo tengo totalmente claro es que china
es un país con todas las capacidades
tecnológicas en ciencia y ciencia
totales hacer genómica para lo para los
chinos es muy sencillo ellos ya tendrían
que tener la respuesta es decir ellos no
la Podrían haber dado hace mucho rato
estudios de epidemiología de campo donde
mostramos el caso cero Y de dónde sale
el caso cero son estudios que se hacen
en general en muchos casos en epidemias
en situaciones de este tipo y y ya para
el tiempo que llevamos Ya era hora de
que los chinos nos hubieran dado pues la
la real verdad Esa a mí me me sigue
haciendo falta así como varias de las
cosas a mí me impresiona mucho que ahora
las noticias estamos mirando que se
toman
fotografías desde no sé dónde para
Mostrar cómo en los sitios en las
funerarias está saturada Qué necesidad
tenemos de tomar fotos aéreas para mirar
la saturación de decir las verdades son
verdades Por qué no nos no tenemos las
verdades a parece que a China le hace
falta eso y yo no sé por qué un problema
político un problema social Pero
definitivamente no es un problema
científico ocultan algo yo yo lo he
sentido Pero esto es mi opinión personal
Daniel Cuál es su opinión aquí hace Es
evidente que el gobierno chino está como
lo decía yo mostrando las cifras a
cuentagotas no le da la información
completa los organismos internacionales
hay críticas por ese tipo de de manejo
de la información qué podría estar
ocultando China y le repito la pregunta
que le hacía la doctora aquí en el
estudio usted tiene alguna teoría a raíz
de todo lo que ha leído y ha visto a lo
largo de estos años de dónde puede
haberse originado esta este coronavirus
o esto dónde pudo haber salido
bueno primero señalar que claramente hay
una falta de transparencia de China del
gobierno de China en dar a conocer las
las verdaderas cifras de incidencia de
ocupación hospitalaria y de mortalidad y
esto no es un fenómeno nuevo es un
fenómeno que se viene dando hace mucho
tiempo y No únicamente con el
coronavirus es un problema estructural y
está ligado a un modelo de gestión
política que lamentablemente no es
transparente ahora bien Yo creo que no
debemos entrar en en consideraciones
conspiratorias o en teorías
conspiratorias lo que en estos momentos
estamos viendo Es que china no dice toda
la magnitud de lo que tiene la la
explosión epidémica que ha tenido el
levantar las restricciones porque no se
quiere dar un tiro en el pie con
respecto a las decisiones que ha tomado
pero yo creo que de ahí a pasar a que
algo se nos está ocultando o que esto
que tiene que ver con un origen también
conspiratorio el virus yo creo que no
deberíamos alimentar ese debate el
debate que tenemos que tener es qué
implica el que se haya desatado la
crisis de la pandemia en China como se
ha desatado y su principal implicación
es el riesgo de que surjan nuevas
variantes que puedan ser más amenazantes
y que escapen a la eficacia vacunal pero
debo decir que al mismo tiempo estamos
enfrentando la variante Kraken en
Estados Unidos que tiene un alto riesgo
de infectividad incrementada y que ha
empezado a mostrar
elementos de escape a la eficacia
vacunal y a la eficacia de los
anticuerpos monoclonales y la misma
pregunta para terminar esta ronda la
doctora
Zulma en la ciudad de Bogotá sus
impresiones de lo que hay en cuanto a la
información tiene usted ya alguna
hipótesis de lo que pudo haber sido el
origen de este virus no estoy aquí
alimentando conspiraciones simplemente
ustedes tienen acceso a información
médica privilegiada a estudios
privilegiados a información que el común
de la gente no tiene de ustedes pueden
tener ya de pronto una teoría en torno a
ese tema y Y pues simplemente quiero
ponerla sobre la mesa
sí Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con las
impresiones que daba el el panelista
anterior el doctor López yo creo que no
existe en este momento digamos no es la
idea como caer en teorías de la
conspiración que nos lleven Más allá de
lo que nos están diciendo estrictamente
los datos
los en los datos vemos un subregistro de
casos la Organización Mundial de la
Salud definitivamente Está tratando de
interceder para que china libere libere
estos números hemos visto que esto ha
pasado en otras epidemias previas
también hay una hay una gran hermetismo
en China sobre porque esto tiene
implicaciones en su economía también y Y
pues obviamente dado el impacto que ha
tenido el virus en otros países Es
lógico que china necesariamente tiene
más casos Pero en cuanto al origen del
virus nos debemos guiar por los informes
y las investigaciones y oficiales y que
han hecho varios científicos en el mundo
pues que apuntan a un origen específico
relacionado con eventos de estilover que
se han desarrollado en China y que
pudieron haberse desarrollado en
cualquier otro lugar del mundo y esa es
la mejor evidencia disponible que
tenemos hasta el momento es decir por
ahora sabemos que en China hay y va a
seguir habiendo un gran impacto de la
pandemia de forma local Cuál será el
impacto más a largo plazo es algo que
estamos pendientes y que tenemos que los
diferentes países colaborar en términos
de vigilancia genómica para ver cuál va
a ser ese potencial impacto por ahora
digamos que estamos expectantes a que se
mejoren esas cifras el reporte de esas
cifras Y hacerle un seguimiento mucho
más juicioso a cómo cómo va la evolución
del virus y sus variantes doctora este
repunte que está viviendo china doctora
en en la ciudad de Bogotá este repunte
que está viviendo china Es parte normal
del desarrollo de este tipo de
de las pandemias es parte del desarrollo
normal de este tipo de situaciones y
China tiene esta característica
particular de tener una baja tasa de
vacunación y por eso se está presentando
este repunte y por eso el caso de China
Puede que no se vea en otros países
alrededor del mundo porque eso es lo que
está teniendo la comunidad internacional
que esto se vaya a volver otra vez unos
repuntes en diferentes países aclaremos
lo y dejémoslo acá puntual
China tiene un escenario particular y no
es igual a otros países
Sí eso es muy importante porque el caso
de China es muy especial por un lado por
el tamaño de su población
en segunda instancia por la baja
cantidad de personas que se ven
infectado previamente es decir ellos de
cierta manera ahorraron esas infecciones
durante tres años pero ahora están
ocurriendo todas muchas de esas
infecciones que no habían ocurrido antes
A diferencia del resto del mundo que
tiene una gran exposición ya en este
punto y también Lamentablemente y
digamos Esa es la parte que que todavía
no es fácil de comprender las tasas de
vacunación no eran las mejores antes de
que se
abrieran estas restricciones entonces
hoy en día sabemos que la mejor
inmunidad protectora que tenemos la más
duradera la más sólida es aquella que
conocemos como inmunidad
híbrida es decir la combinación de dosis
de vacuna con sus refuerzos y
adicionalmente la infección pre es decir
poblaciones que se han expuesto tanto a
altas tasas de vacunación más
unas tasas altas de infección son
aquellas que por ahora permanecen
estando en más protección y de forma más
duradera China tiene en ambas
situaciones unas tasas bajas entonces
bajo ese
escenario lo más Lógico es que en estos
momentos estén experimentando una gran
ola de contagios que está su
diagnosticada su recortada pero que está
sucediendo y y un alto número de muertes
que se va a ver muy grande en el momento
en que esa cifra se liberen de la forma
más parecida como la han liberado otros
países y y que va a tener un alto
impacto en el número total a nivel
global pero no necesariamente ese
impacto se va a reflejar en otros países
pasó a preguntarle ahora a Daniel
haciendo la ronda la inversa doctora
María Fernanda ya le doy la palabra
usted tocaba el tema de la vacunación Ya
lo hemos mencionado acá Daniel la baja
vacunación que tiene China para una
población tan grande entonces qué se
puede decir entonces de estas vacunas de
fabricación china que también fueron
vendidas a otros países dio mucho de que
hablar Este término de la diplomacia de
las vacunas china le regaló lotes
inmensos a muchísimos países alrededor
del mundo son efectivas estas vacunas
chinas o claramente para este virus en
particular resulta más efectiva más
eficiente el otro tipo de vacunas
desarrolladas del ARN mensajero
Bueno lo primero es señalar que
las vacunas utilizadas en China tienen
una eficacia probada porque si no no
habrían sido ni aprobadas por sus
autoridades sanitarias ni una de ellas
validada por la OMS pero no tienen la
misma eficacia que las vacunas de ARN o
que otras vacunas que han sido usadas en
países occidentales
dicho esto yo creo que es muy importante
entender que
parte del problema de la eficacia
vacunal es que tenemos vacunas todas las
que se aplican también en occidente que
no tienen una duración prolongada que
bajan su efectividad al cabo de seis
meses a un año que es necesario reforzar
la protección inmunológica y mucho más
con una vacuna bivalente como la que se
está aplicando en Europa en estos
momentos o en Estados Unidos que también
protege contra las las variantes o
sublinajes de omi y que lamentablemente
no se está aplicando en América Latina y
esto nos puede dejar en gran medida en
los países de América Latina con una
desprotección relativa por último nada
más señalar que el cuando hay un
problema en un país en una pandemia en
ningún país es una isla y esto acaba
teniendo implicaciones y repercusiones
para el resto del mundo los países más
pobres tienen una muy baja tasa de
vacunación solo el veinticinco por
ciento de la población en los países más
pobres ha recibido cuando menos una
dosis entonces evidentemente un repunte
de casos y una dinámica de transmisión
intensificada va a tener un impacto
especialmente en los países más pobres o
los que están desprotegidos con la
digamos por la falta de una adecuada
eficacia vacunal o de lo suficiente
refuerzos de vacunas si es algo que den
evidencia con esta pandemia doctora
María Fernanda fue justamente la
desigualdad a la hora de acceder a las a
las a vacunas
por parte de los países menos
favorecidos yo tengo que decir que tengo
las tres dosis de vacunas chinas y hasta
ahora perfecto nunca he tenido covid por
lo menos que yo sepa entonces pues bueno
mal que viene eso ha funcionado así sea
en China no sean del ARN mensajero pero
pero me ha servido para mantenerme
aislado del virus paso a preguntarle
doctora María Fernanda por las medidas
que también han sido muy criticadas por
el gobierno de Beijing de imponer
restricciones a Los viajeros este tipo
de restricciones de volver otra vez a
hacer las pruebas y todo esto en los
aeropuertos esto verdaderamente previene
contagios en el mediano plazo Estos son
son políticas acertadas para prevenir
que haya repuntes de casos Pues aquí las
preocupaciones son las nuevas variantes
que haya nuevas variantes y esas nuevas
variantes se generan cuando hay mucho
virus diferente circulando Entonces los
reportes ahoritica están de decir china
está diciendo tenemos
150 160 variantes circulando pero son
las mismas que han circulado a lo largo
tiempo por decir la nueva nueva
las nuevas son más más recientes y son
mucho menos en números entonces pues la
discusión es
los países europeos y nosotros en
general ya estamos muy muy vacunados
nosotros ya estamos muy expuestos hemos
estado muy expuestos al virus usted
tiene tres dosis de vacuna yo tengo tres
dosis de vacuna y he tenido dos cobits
fíjese usted y sí me vacuné con vacunas
rna entonces pues eso es
eso se estaba dando por las variaciones
etcétera Pero lo que sí es claro es que
la vacunación ha disminuido
profundamente la mortalidad y nosotros
usted estaba hablando ahoritica de
desigualdad y yo me acordaba del
problema que tuvimos al principio con la
gente mayor que a la gente mayor le
dieron sinovac y a la gente después en
la siguiente grupo Entonces ya le dieron
entonces la gente mayor decía y por qué
a mí no me dan otra entonces eso y hubo
discusiones porque todo el mundo pensaba
que la crna era mucho más efectivas que
sinovac sin embargo nosotros en nuestro
país al una disminución Clara de la
mortalidad en las personas mayores
entonces a mí personalmente es decir
sabemos científicamente que las vacunas
de rna son mucho mejores que las vacunas
de este virus sinovac que es un virus
inactivado completo pero no le podemos
quitar el mérito es decir esto mucho por
nosotros y pues mucha gente se ha
vacunado como usted con tres dosis de
sinovac y no más entonces pues es eso
eso es lo que hemos tenido
desafortunadamente no no hay no hay la
comparación la podemos tener con otros
países como por ejemplo con la china que
no ha tenido sino vacunas chinas
Aparentemente pero pues qué está pasando
o qué qué qué problema hay de que los la
gente china salga de la China o que
nosotros vayamos a la china Pues yo creo
que es el mismo que estamos corriendo a
lo largo del tiempo con con el medio en
medio ambiente tiene tiene virus
nosotros es decir Ya se acabó la
pandemia Esa es la siguiente ya estamos
en pues Muchos decimos ya estamos en un
proceso de adaptación a la endemia pero
vamos a tener virus toda la vida este
virus llegó como dicen por ahí para
quedarse Entonces tenemos que adaptarnos
a él y convivir con él yo Esa es mi
posición con respecto a eso bueno Y
entonces En qué fase estamos de todo
este desarrollo normal de una pandemia
En qué fase estamos pues mucha gente
dice que estamos en inicio de la endemia
otros dicen que no se ha terminado la
pandemia en los epidemiólogos ese corte
Pues yo creo que la línea no está lo
único que sí tenemos claro es que
tenemos virus en este momento en
Colombia este estamos en una época de de
infecciones respiratorias que este virus
está mezclando con otros virus
respiratoria lo que ha congestionado la
historia además de las unidades de
médicas pero lo ha congestionado la
historia entonces pues en esos En eso
estamos esperar que haya un rebrote por
cuenta de nuevas variantes existe la
posibilidad porque todas las
posibilidades en biología existen uno no
puede decir que no a nada pero pues ya
tenemos mucha inmunidad por lo menos
Comparado con hace dos años Estamos
mucho más adelantados
con la doctora
Zulma cucunova sobre la fase en la que
estamos usted doctora En cuál fase cree
que estamos en este momento y y que
medidas podemos tener para seguir
colaborando para para que se reduzca el
contagio se reduzca la cantidad de
personas contagiadas volvemos entonces a
fomentar la vacunación Qué se puede
hacer de Cara a seguir en este proceso
para salir adelante
bueno es una pregunta muy importante En
qué fase estamos digamos
epidemiológicamente desde la
epidemiología de enfermedades
infecciosas lo que define un estado de
equilibrio endémico es aquel donde el
número de reproducción efectiva es
equivalente a uno es decir donde existe
predictibilidad en En cuándo va a
ocurrir Y si ocurren o no
incrementos brotes y también la mayoría
del tiempo es una cifra constante ese
estado en domicilidad no lo hemos tenido
por unos periodos muy largos dentro de
la pandemia si acaso en algunos países
hemos tenido esos periodos por un máximo
de unos tres cuatro cinco meses donde
existe una transmisión estable baja y
predecible pero luego vuelven a aparecer
nuevos picos es decir como tal todavía
yo Considero que no existen argumentos
sólidos de epidemiología
dinámica para decir que estemos en un
estado de endemia Sin embargo sí es
cierto que impacto sobre la mortalidad
que en últimas
es todos estos desenlaces severos son
los que más nos importan la
hospitalización la mortalidad la
discapacidad ese impacto ha venido
disminuyendo a medida que van pasando
las diferentes zonas qué es lo que
probablemente podría pasar porque ha
pasado con otros con otros virus y es
que lleguemos a una situación donde
tengamos un estado estacional donde
tengamos algunas épocas de endemicidad
con algunos rebrotes que estén
dados por disminución parcial de la
inmunidad que sabemos que ocurre tanto
con vacunas como con la inmunidad
infección previa y que puedan de alguna
manera Está relacionados también con
variaciones
estacionales del clima es decir lo que
la mayoría de nosotros es como
epidemiólogos esperamos es que vamos a
seguir experimentando olas de contagio
en el futuro
pero no sabemos qué magnitud puedan
tener presumimos que la magnitud de esas
olas sobre todo el impacto en
hospitalización y muerte por lo que
hemos visto en el último año cada vez
van a ser relativamente más pequeñas
para china no es el caso porque es la
primera vez con una población que estaba
bastante susceptible
y pues habremos en el futuro digamos
cada vez que tengamos estas olas en los
diferentes países sería recomendable
seguir algunas medidas de cuidado básico
Como por ejemplo el uso de mascarillas
claro el uso de ventilación en algunos
lugares de de donde sea más más posible
el riesgo de contagio claro no hay que
bajar la guardia sobre todo si estamos
en esa fase Daniel Ya teniendo claro un
poco el panorama de de lo que estamos en
este momento de la pandemia En qué fase
estamos es momento apropiado también
para hacer un poco de evaluación lo que
nos ha dejado esta pandemia a la
humanidad en términos médicos cientí
como sociedad y también con el manejo de
la que le dieron a la situación los
diferentes gobiernos y los diferentes
organismos internacionales entendiendo
Pues que todavía estamos en en esta
situación que esto no no es un capítulo
cerrado en la historia de la humanidad
definitivamente no es un capítulo
cerrado yo quisiera insistir como
epidemiólogo en que la pandemia no ha
terminado que no estamos en una fase
endémica coincido fundamentalmente con
lo que señaló Zulma no lo voy a repetir
pero yo creo que en estos momentos lo
que tenemos es una dinámica
epidemiológica bastante amenazante que
tenemos que no tener pánico ni alarma
pero sí estar alertas y cautelosos y
vigilantes por el surgimiento de una
variante mucho más agresiva con
tendencias escapar a las vacunas como la
Kraken que está asolando los Estados
Unidos Especialmente los estados del
este de Estados Unidos y por la dinámica
de la pandemia en Chile entonces bueno
volviendo a la pregunta Claro que
tenemos que evaluar continuamente yo
creo que hemos sido demasiado lentos en
esta evaluación quienes estamos
acostumbrados a gestionar situaciones de
crisis sabemos que lo importante es
hacer evaluaciones en tiempo real para
poder rec de inmediato aquello que no
está haciendo hecho adecuadamente la
pandemia nos ha dejado muchas lecciones
pero no todas ellas las estamos
internalizando y fundamentalmente está
viendo una baja capacidad de entender
que tenemos que tener mejores
preparativos pandémicos mejor capacidad
de planes de contingencia que esta no es
la última pandemia que vamos a enfrentar
y con respecto a esta pandemia que
tenemos que mantener una protección
vacunal Especialmente con formulaciones
renovadas de la vacuna que defiendan
contra las nuevas variantes y que no
podemos bajar la guardia con respecto a
algunas medidas de protección como el
uso de la mascarilla especialmente la
temporada otoño invernal doctor continuó
con usted porque veo que insiste en la
variante Kraken que está afectando como
dice usted el este de Estados Unidos una
zona de ese país que ha estado muy
afectada por las tormentas invernales en
las últimas semanas ha sido intenso el
frío allí eso también pues ya lo sabemos
potencia todos estos virus
en el invierno boreal austral
dependiendo donde uno se encuentre Pero
qué particularidades tiene Entonces esta
variante que hemos hablado muy poco de
ella por lo menos en la región de
América Latina
si se está hablando poco en América
Latina no en Estados Unidos no en Europa
en Europa preocupa también Y es que se
trata de un de una modalidad del virus
que es recombinante que es la fusión de
dos subvariantes o perdón de dos
sublinajes de la variante omicron que
tiene más capacidad de infectar las
células que tiene más contagiosidad que
se que propicia una infección muy rápida
y que ya la fud and droga administration
ha mostrado claramente que evade la
eficacia de anticuerpos monoclonales
entonces en estos momentos ocupa
mayoritariamente el escenario de la
epidemiología del virus en el este de
Estados Unidos pero se está expandiendo
rápidamente hay casos ya en Europa y
estoy seguro que en un mes a mes y medio
vamos a tener una dominancia de esta
variante lo que más nos preocupa es que
puede escapar a la eficacia vacunal
especialmente de la vacuna bivalente
Pero por eso yo creo que lo que tenemos
que insistir es en que nuestras mejores
armas para evitar tanto un repunte de
crack en como lo que pueda venir de
China es mantener la protección vacunal
con dosis reforzadas de vacuna bivalente
y mantener las medidas de secuenciación
genómica de pruebas diagnósticas y de
uso de mascarilla en interiores mal
ventilados pues hay que dar la
explicación del doctor Daniel ya me
quedan un par de minutos para finalizar
el programa doctora María Fernanda
conclusiones de lo que podemos decir del
tema chino y de lo que nos sigue aquí en
adelante con este tema de la pandemia
Kobe 19 su reflexión para el cierre no
yo creo que lo más importante es no
olvidar las lecciones aprendidas porque
estoy de acuerdo con el doctor y no
solamente en un par de cosas en muchas
nosotros es como si se fue nos dijeron
No no mascarilla y Y la verdad el
desorden Por lo menos en nuestros países
fue ha sido fuerte entonces me pareció
importante tener claro que esto sucede
que el virus llegó para quedarse que es
decir que variantes se pueden volver a
podemos volver a tener que las la
vacunación es la estrategia sin duda y
que tenemos que mantenerla como pues
principal las otras medidas también son
importantes pero la vacunación es
fundamental y la verdad es es darle un
poquito de tiempo a que el virus
estabilice que es una de las esperanzas
de todos los virus tienden a
estabilizarse ellos no se quedan todo el
tiempo
cambiando pues de una manera pues uno sí
el virus de la influenza cambia
anualmente pero en general no no con
esta agresividad con la que lo había
estado estaba haciendo el virus el dos
doctora Zulma su conclusión rápidamente
bueno la principal conclusión es que
vivimos en un mundo globalizado cosas
que están pasando en algunos países en
algún momento podrían llegar a
afectarnos también en nuestros propios
países es muy importante que nuestros
sistemas de salud sigan fortaleciéndose
en el sentido de los equipos de
vigilancia genómica a partir de este año
va a ser muy importante para determinar
las futuras campañas de vacunación
programas de vacunación que vamos a
tener en el futuro para esta enfermedad
va a ser muy importante cómo hacemos y
combinamos esa vigilancia genómica a
nivel global y para la comunidad general
lo más importante es en temporada alta
de transmisión de virus respiratorios es
recomendable utilizar alguna protección
como mascarillas de alta filtración
ventilación sobre todo en lugares
concurridos y cerrados y y pues estar
muy pendientes de lo que las autoridades
indiquen para cada estación de alta
transmisión
pues les agradezco a los tres por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el programa
el doctor Daniel a la doctora Zulma la
doctora María Fernanda gracias por haber
estado con nosotros Tratamos de aclarar
las dudas principales en torno a este
tema ya saben vacunación y la prevención
la clave para seguir haciendo frente a
esta situación del Coby 19 que no ha
terminado la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
[Música]